pause this video and see if you can
evaluate this expression before we do it
together
all right now let's work on this
together and we see that we have a lot
of different operations here we have
exponents we have multiplication we have
addition we have division we have
parentheses and so to interpret this
properly we just have to remind
ourselves of the order of operations
so you start with parentheses then go to
exponents then multiplication division
then addition and subtraction so we see
that we're going to whatever is over
here we're eventually going to square it
that's the only place that we have the
parentheses but how are we going to
evaluate what's inside of these
parentheses
so let's then think about all right we
have an exponent here
that we can evaluate we know that 2
squared is the same thing as 2 times 2
which is the same thing as 4.
no more exponents to evaluate so then we
go to multiplication and division
so we know by how this fraction sign is
written that we need to evaluate the
numerator and then divide it by the
entire denominator right over here
now in this numerator we have to remind
ourselves that we do this multiplication
before we do this addition we don't just
go left to right
so we know that it's one plus and i
could put parentheses here to really
emphasize that we do the multiplication
first so before this gets too messy let
me just rewrite everything i'm going to
do this multiplication up here first and
actually in the denominator i'm going to
do this multiplication first as well
so this is all going to simplify to
1 over 14 or 1 14
times now this numerator here is going
to be 1
plus
4 times 3 4 times 3 is
12.
all of that is going to be over
7
plus
2 times 3 which is of course equal to 6
and then i am going to have our plus 1
here and then i square everything
well now we can evaluate this numerator
and this denominator find another color
to do it in
this numerator 1 plus 12 is going to be
equal to
13 and 7 plus 6 interestingly is also
equal to 13. so we have 1 14 or 1
divided by 14 times this whole thing
squared and inside you have 13 divided
by 13 plus 1. well we know we need to do
division before we do addition so we
will want to evaluate this part before
we do the addition what is 13 divided by
13 well that's just going to be equal to
1.
so
i can rewrite this as 1 over 14
times
1
plus
1
all of that squared
and now we'll want to do this
parentheses so let's do that 1 plus 1 is
going to be equal of course to 2
and then we're going to do the exponents
2 squared is of course equal to
4
and then we're going to multiply 1 over
14 times 4. now you could interpret this
and they're equivalent you could say hey
this is the same thing as multiplying 1
14 times 4 or you could say this is the
same thing as multiplying 1 times 4
divided by 14.
times four divided by fourteen
either way you look at it you're going
to get four
over fourteen and we're done if you want
you could rewrite this by dividing both
the numerator and the denominator by 2
and you could get 2 over 7 but that's
how we can how we can evaluate this
pretty complex expression just step by
step looking at what we can simplify
first